[Music]
me
[Music]
english lessons
hello everyone today's mini english
lesson is all about homophones what does
the chess piece say before bed night
night is that funny you should never
explain a joke the joke is funny because
they use homophones
homophones are when two words sound the
same but they have a different spelling
and maybe they even have a different
definition or both in this case night
like good night
and night
like being knighted by the queen
when we sit down to spell these words it
can be really difficult even for native
speakers their house is so great i'm so
glad i went there
what there
possessive
you can imagine that the eye has a
person's face
whereas there
as in location you can imagine all the
other location words
where
here
and there spellings match
use a mnemonic device that's fancy
teacher talk for a trip to help you
remember how to spell it to sum it all
up a homophone is a word that sounds the
same but is spelled differently
and may mean something different than
the word it sounds like
i hope that you found my joke as
hilarious as i did
thank you for joining us and see you
next time
[Music]